ah
good morning guys
uh so we rounded everybody up got
everybody here that's good
um so we are looking at HB 71 so I'd
like to call the work session uh to
order and um we had we heard quite a bit
of testimony on uh the spell yesterday
which I found helpful
um just as a reminder there are two
components to it uh part one which
increases the primathacia presumption of
cancer disease and firefighters to all
kinds of cancer
and then the second to set up a
commission to study the implementation
of optional annual cancer screenings
um I'll start the conversation this
morning by just saying I've had
a few conversations since yesterday
particularly about this study commission
and there is some concern
um
with the fact that we're going to need
to find eight legislators to serve on
that and how effective the commission
will be if we have to have that many of
us on there and not other experts and it
should be studied but is it better left
studied to other groups of people
um so I'll just throw that out there and
then allow conversation to ensue Peter
which thank you very much Mr chairman
first of all my apologize apologies to
everyone uh I somehow when I was in the
Marine Corps many many years ago decades
ago
the whole company would be out there
falling out for inspection
wouldn't be the whole company there will
all be a couple of people staggering out
of the Barrack store going like what's
going on oh we're here out for
inspection oh I didn't get the word well
I didn't get the word either about
yesterday so I wasn't here my apologies
but I do have a question and that is uh
remind me again that you mentioned eight
members of the legislature on this study
committee how many of them are proposed
to be from the Senate two two
so typically as as some of us have
experienced in the past the Senate looks
at any number that's not one and says
we're going to convert two or three into
one Senator because they don't have the
troops to to have a full contingent that
the house will or the sponsor will set
up so uh but this is it everyone else's
opinion that that uh six legislature six
house members seems like a lot
it is it's a lot and the concern is that
it's just not really going to happen
um exactly because
nobody's questioning
the importance of the study itself or
that we don't need the information and I
understand yeah I understand why they
want to do it and I'm actually somewhat
in support of why they want to do it
um it's just a matter of whether or not
this is a legislative responsibility or
if there is a better Avenue to do that
um is there any is there any thought
among the subcommittee that we should
perhaps reduce the number of of house
members from six to three the typical
number of house members that are on the
study committee so it's not a committee
it's a commission well and so the well
the problem is is according to statute
we need to be in the majority on the
committee and so to get the set the
seven other people that we that they
would like on it to get you know the
um kind of breadth of
representation that they want we'd have
to have eight eight legislators if we
reduce us we'll have to reduce them as
well and then you really start running
into do you have the people on it that
you need I take your point entirely
thank you
um so that that's one section that I'm I
would like to personally I would like to
see section one go through regardless I
I think it's reasonable
um which is the Primus Prima fascia
presumption that cancer disease
um
is is caused by the occupational hazard
um I was I'm pretty much okay with that
I don't know what other people's
feelings on it
press yeah I'm expecting you to say
something
thank you Mr chair
um
the uh
the commission aside and now we're
talking about section one yes
um
ruminating over it last night
and some of the tests and trying to
compare that with some of the testimony
oddly enough I still do have a problem
with
it shall just be assumed that all
cancers in the world
will be workman's comp related
so once again for clarification on that
because I I don't think that's quite the
position
if it's reasonable when all of the other
considerations are taken into account of
Life habits and all of the other things
that they take into consideration
um the evidence doesn't strongly point
one way or the other and it's in those
finely defined cases where they're not
you know it could go it could be
occupational it could not be
occupational
the presumption is just that it's in
favor of the firefighter and not in the
favor of the insurance company
essentially the workman's comp company
so
it's it's not open it's open to any form
of cancer but you would still have to
make a good case about how that would be
related
yeah representative Gerhard thank you
chairman the only thing I'm concerned
about is
kind of creating a moral hazard
situation where the government's
subsidizing the effect of using
cancer-causing materials if there was
actually a cost associated with using
these which is really people's lives
instead of just paying them basically
blood money to use this stuff wouldn't
it kind of be
important to encourage the creation of
something else do you know what I'm
trying to get at does that make any
sense so that's it that's what I'm kind
of dealing with I think I think that
everybody agrees with you and there's
been a lot of conversation about that
obviously we're learning new things and
so we need to come up with new Solutions
so we didn't realize that we're
cancer-causing outfits now we're now
we're starting to question whether they
are they seem to be
um and so we're limiting the use of them
but we don't have a solution to that
problem and we can't come up with a
solution to that problem like today so
knowing that we've put them in this
position I guess the question is what's
the right thing to do knowing that we've
put them in this position because uh you
know they've been they've been wearing
these suits right along and so
um
if they're causing people to have more
kinds of cancer
those things will are going to pop up
and how do we handle the fact that
they're popping up you know like we
can't retroactively keep them from
wearing the suits understood but what's
to
keep this from happening in the future
in a sense there's just the hope that
eventually somebody say okay I feel bad
about the situation occurring I'm going
to change or do you know what I'm trying
to get at that's what I'm just sure so
that's the only thing I I think the only
information that we have on that is that
they are trying to minimize the amount
that they're wearing the suits for
example they do have they do go into
detox when they get back
um which didn't used to be the case
um I would assume that we as legislators
have potentially a responsibility to
look into it and maybe take action in
the future but once again
you know I'm not sure that that directly
overlaps with whether or not we give
them the presumption of cancer now we
can always take away the presumption of
cancer later if enough that's been
mitigated but I doubt that would happen
um but you know that's I think that's
what we're given consideration to
Peter
thank you so I mean uh we several years
ago uh
we had a bill about these firefighting
foams
which were standard in especially in
aviation related fires
which are of a very different nature in
many cases than the standard building
fire and it was discovered that these
Foams were
loaded with
uh one of the P5 P5 type chemicals uh
and in the meantime that particular
type of foam has been done away with uh
and it's they still have some
firefighting Foams but they are much
less uh laced with very dangerous
chemicals and it and we were told at the
time that one of the graduation
uh celebrations for firefighters
finishing their training was to get
doused with uh that that that's a
chemical the firefighting foam uh and
even that sometimes in the schools they
would be playing the kids would play
around with the stuff uh and were
um and and maybe there are other things
that that are cancer-causing that are
fun I've not done any experimentation
nor do I intend to but but the thing is
there was a lot of money there was a lot
of money that was spent in
um in developing new
firefighting Foams now most fire
departments do not
use that stuff because it's primarily
designed for Aviation
fires which are you know you're dealing
with lots and lots of uh jet fuel
which is very flammable and very
dangerous and there's a lot of it so
that you need that kind you need some
kind of foam to fight them effectively
so in this particular instance if we're
if these guys are suited up in in
outfits which they need to survive
in that particular instance
you can't walk in without being fully
suited up
and having
breathing apparatus all that other kind
of stuff so to the degree that they have
to wear that or they're going to die on
the spot in that fire then we are
expecting them to do something which is
extremely hazardous and which almost
certainly will produce some kind of
negative effect
later on I I think
if you're going to pay the price you get
to go to the dance so I I'm that's not
going to deter me from supporting uh
this you know this
expansion or extension of the coverage
thank you thank you
okay I will I will yes oh sorry go ahead
representative and I I apologize I
apologize to the subcommittee but not at
all here I go again
um and and I I discussed this not in uh
I realized that in testimony we heard
that the cost of this
is probably going to be minimal
because there won't be that many cases
of of cancer coming in to workman's comp
new cases that's going to drive the cost
to the cities and towns
but that's just a guess nobody knows
what's what it's going to cost
uh or if it would be inconsequential or
substantial
it's just not known
hmm
but saying that
it is just assumed that any cancer that
cancer
will be work related
as as it states
in addition to the ones that are already
that we got in the handout listed as
these uh work these are workman's comp
and we were given uh uh the uh the uh
example of I think it was testicular
cancer
where that's not covered
and uh
I I don't remember if it was not proven
that it was work related or it was
disproven that it was it was disproven
um I believe correct
I was just asking for clarification
Mr will is in the backseating
uh I'm good at the moment yeah I just
so
if we pass section one
that testicular cancer would be presumed
to be work related
right uh just for clarification Mr role
was is testicular cancer on the list or
it's not yes
so it would have been presumed it would
have been presumed to be work related it
was found not to be work related so they
denied the claim
so that this was a situation where that
is on the list testicular cancer is
presumed to be work related unless
otherwise proven and they proved that it
wasn't that was the point of that part
of the testimony I believe to show that
just because it's presumed doesn't mean
that they'll get the
that they'll get the claim but we'll
all right uh section two sorry this is a
little tricky because we're basically
dealing with two different bills in the
same bill and we're gonna have to sort
that out
yes I got
today I like it you're you're hopping we
get about 15 minutes here before we got
to be out of the room just so everybody
knows maybe 20.
I don't see any reason why
this information could not be gotten
without
a commission
um needed information
uh
people can get together and get that
information
uh compiled I I just think a
a commission is not needed
yes
I think I mentioned the other day we
were talking about this the Wi-Fi and
cellular radiation commission that was
conducted in 2020
they put out a report said this stuff is
really bad we need 1500 foot setbacks
and nothing's ever happened since so I
don't really know if you need
Representatives on a situate on a board
like that just to have nothing happen
there's the the people who know
the material already know the material
and it's simply a matter of presentation
I think that's the whole concept so
yeah I don't really see the benefit
unless we can guarantee that something
actually will occur upon the execution
of the Commission
okay
um so I have an amendment uh
for the commission side cleaning up the
language to what it needed to be
um
if we decide to to move forward with
section two it doesn't sound like most
of the subcommittee is in favor of that
um from what people have said but in
case that is the case we had to change
the effective date we needed to change
slightly the um composition of the
commission
um
so I do have an amendment that fixes
that language
um
if we do decide to go in that direction
I guess at this point having listened to
what everyone has to say I would make
the motion I'll have to get an amendment
before our exact session if we were
going to do this but I would make a a
motion to keep part one
in the bill and strike the commission
strike part two out of the bill and try
to come up with a separate solution to
that
that would that would be more
I have a second all right
um
I'll just call the role representative
Schmidt
okay okay
representative yeah you've got until
this afternoon representative Schmidt
representative Davis
yeah I suppose what you were just saying
about passing the first part and
strike in a second yeah all right
representative Gerhard
all right
so I got 4-0 on that I'll bring that
we'll bring that then to the executive
session this afternoon and see how
everybody else feels about it
yes
so I have the amendment so if the full
exec session if the full committee
decides that they want to keep the
commission I have the language to I have
an amendment
clean up that language so we can bring
that Amendment forward at that time just
so that it's all in order in case it
goes forward so
all right you got a half an hour we'll